the cowboys
am i really gonna do it yeah i'll do it
now sweating a little bit as it relates
to the contract of ezekiel elliott and
elliot had been very quiet very coy not
even coy he had been all in with the
fact that he still has two years left on
his deal in dallas and that the cowboys
had yet to turn their attention to his
contract instead focusing on dak
prescott and amari cooper because both
of those players have contracts that
expire after this year well elliott two
years left on his deal apparently not
waiting around to be
eventually in line for his new contract
i was told yesterday that he's privately
telling people he intends to hold out
without a new contract charles robinson
of yahoo followed that up with a report
that that doesn't entirely mesh
with what we reported but it is easy to
harmonize and the bottom line is this
before yesterday nobody thought there
was any issue whatsoever between elliot
and the cowboys it's now clear that
something is up and that this week may
be critical to whether or not elliott
does indeed show up for camp now
robinson says elliot hasn't made a final
decision about whether he will hold out
without a new contract
i'm told he's telling people that he's
going to hold out maybe that's just a
trial balloon maybe that's a way to get
the team's attention so they'll take the
situation seriously and if they don't
it could be that one of their most
important players doesn't show up for
the start of training camp and he has
leverage this is different than melvin
gordon for a couple of reasons first of
all
ezekiel elliott is a truly special
running back and the definition of
special running backs changes every year
i see three right now in the nfl elliot
saquon barkley christian mccaffrey now
there are others who could join that
list this year and some of those three
could fall off it changes every year
joe mixon of the bengals could end up
being a special running back based upon
what happens this season for now though
it's elliott
barkley and mccaffrey also
it's a very important year for the
dallas cowboys beyond the fact that the
offense is changing potentially
dramatically
coach jason garrett coaching for his job
this year in the final year of his
contract and also look jerry jones the
owner of the team has made it clear he
desperately wants to win another super
bowl in his lifetime and
he has been very candid about the
reality that he doesn't know how many
more opportunities he's going to have to
try to win another super bowl with a
team
not that jimmy johnson built but with a
team that jerry jones built and they
think they're close
without ezekiel elliott
they're not close
and remember 1993
emmett smith wanted a new contract from
the cowboys
he held out
oh by the way he also had three seasons
in just like elliot smith held out
into the regular season oh and two were
the cowboys and jerry jones finally
blinked emmitt smith came back with his
new contract and he ended up helping the
team toward a second straight super bowl
win and remember it was week 17 in 1993
that heroic performance from emmett
smith with his shoulder injured it was a
game against the giants that determined
the number one seed versus being the
number five seed in the nfc huge
performance from smith huge performances
expected this year from ezekiel elliott
and elliott needs to remember what
happened with demarco murray last year
of his contract with the cowboys led the
league in rushing set the single season
franchise record for rushing a record
that still stands despite eliot's three
years in the nfl and demarco murray
didn't get a new contract had to leave
via free agency and get paid somewhere
else so that could be what the cowboys
ultimately do with ezekiel elliott when
his five-year contract ends or maybe
it's five years and a year of the
franchise tag and then they let him walk
away either way the fact that he is
taking a stand if he indeed is and it
sure sounds like it it's smart
because now is the time to apply the
leverage to the cowboys to get what
elliott wants
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports